cancer it's a devastating disease that
takes an enormous emotion at all not
only on the patient but the patient's
loved ones as well it is a battle that
the human race has been fighting for
centuries and while we've made some
advancements we still haven't beaten it
two out of five people in the US will
develop cancer in their lifetime of
those 90 percent will succumb to the
disease due to metastasis metastasis is
a spread of cancer from a primary site
to a distal site through the circulatory
or the lymphatic system for instance a
female patient with breast cancer
doesn't succumb to the disease simply
because she has a mass on her breast she
succumbs to disease because it spreads
to the lungs liver lymph nodes brain
born where it becomes unresectable or
untreatable metastasis is a complicated
process one that I've studied for
several years now and something that my
team and I discovered recently was that
cancer cells are able to communicate
with each other and coordinate their
movement based on how closely packed
they are in the tumor microenvironment
they communicate with each other through
two signaling molecules called
interleukin 6 and interleukin 8 now like
anything else in nature when things get
a little too tight the signal is
enhanced causing the cancer cells to
move away faster from the primary site
and spread to a new site so if we block
the signal using a drug cocktail that we
developed we can stop the communication
between cancer cells and slow down the
spread of cancer let me pause here for a
second and take you back to when this
all began for me in 2010 when I was just
a sophomore in college
I had just started working in dr. Denny
Watson's lab at Johns Hopkins University
and I'll be honest I was a young naive
Sri Lankan girl who had no previous
research experience and I was tasked to
look at how cancer cells moved in a 3d
collagen one matrix that recaps elated
in a dish the conditions that cancer
cells are exposed to in our bodies this
was new and exciting for me because
previous work had been done on 2d flat
plastic dishes that really weren't
representative of what the cancer cells
are exposed to in our bodies because
let's face it the cancer cells in our
bodies aren't stuck onto plastic dishes
it was during this time that I attended
a seminar conducted by dr. Bonnie bezler
from Princeton University where she
talked about how bacterial cells
communicate with each other based on
their population density and perform a
specific action it was at this moment
that a light bulb went off in my head
and I thought wow I see this in my
cancer cells every day when it comes to
their movement the idea for my project
was the spawn I hypothesized that cancer
cells are able to communicate with each
other and coordinate their movement
based on how closely packed they are in
the tumor microenvironment I became
obsessed with pursuing this hypothesis
and fortunately I work for someone who
was open to running with my crazy ideas
so I threw myself into this project
however I couldn't do it by myself I
needed help I definitely needed help so
we recruited undergraduate students
graduate students postdoctoral fellows
and professors from different
institutions and multiple different
disciplines to come together and work on
this idea that I conceived as a
sophomore in college
after years of conducting experiments
together and merging different ideas and
perspectives we discovered a new
signaling pathway that controls how
cancer cells communicate with each other
and move based on the cell density some
of you might have heard this because
most of social media knows it as the
Hosny effect and we weren't done yet we
then decided that we want to block this
signaling pathway and see if we could
slow down the spread of cancer which we
did in preclinical animal models we came
up with a drug cocktail consisting of
costly zoom AB which is currently used
to treat rheumatoid arthritis and rapper
axon which is currently in clinical
trials against breast cancer and
interestingly what we found was that
this cocktail of drug really had no
effect on tumor growth but directly
targeted metastases this was a
significant finding because currently
there aren't any fda approved therapy
dicks that directly target the spread of
cancer in fact the spread of cancer
metastases is thought of as a byproduct
of tumor growth where the idea is if we
can stop the tumor from growing we can
stop the tumor from spreading however
most of us know that this is not true we
on the other hand came up with a drug
cocktail that targets metastases not by
targeting tumor growth but by targeting
the complex mechanisms that govern it
through the targeting of the Hosny
effect this work was recently published
in Nature communications and my team and
I received an overwhelming response from
around the world nobody on my team could
have predicted this sort of response we
seem to have struck a nerve
looking back
extremely grateful for the positive
response that I received not only from
academia but also patients and people
around the world affected by this
terrible disease as I reflect on this
success that I've encountered with the
Hosny effect I keep coming back to the
people that I was fortunate enough to
work with the undergraduate students who
demonstrated superhuman powers through
their hard work and dedication the
graduate students and the postdoctoral
fellows my fellow Avengers who taught me
new techniques and always made sure I
stayed on track
the professor's my Yoda's and my obi-wan
Kenobi's who brought their expertise
into making this work into what it is
today
the support stars the friends and family
people who lifted our spirits and never
let us give up on our ambitious
endeavors the best kind of sidekicks we
could have asked for it took a village
to help me study metastasis and believe
me without my village I wouldn't be here
today our team has grown and we are
using the Hosny effect to develop
combination therapies that will
effectively target tumor growth and
metastasis
we are engineering new anti-cancer
therapeutics to limit toxicity and to
reduce drug resistance and we are
developing groundbreaking systems that
will help for the development of better
human clinical trials it blows my mind
to think that all this the incredible
work that I'm pursuing and the fact that
I'm standing here talking to you today
all came from this tiny idea that I had
when I was sitting at the back of a
seminar when I was just 20 years old I
recognize that right now I am on this
incredible journey that allows me to
pursue work that I am extremely
passionate about and something that
feeds my curiosity on a daily basis but
I have to say my favorite part of all of
this other than of course being here
talking to you today is the fact that I
get to work with a diverse group of
people who make my work stronger better
and just so much more fun and because of
this I have to say that collaboration is
my favorite superhuman power and what I
love about this power is that it's not
unique to me it's within all of us my
work shows that even cancer cells use
collaboration to invade our bodies and
spread their wrath for us humans it is a
superpower that has produced incredible
discoveries in the medical and
scientific field and it is a superpower
that we can all turn to to inspire us to
create something bigger than ourselves
that will help make the world a better
place
collaboration is the superpower that I
turn to to help me fight cancer and I am
confident that with the right
collaborations we will beat this
terrible disease thank you
[Applause]